welcome back to las vegas now miracle
flights the sponsors of this next
segment has partnered with downtown
summerlin to make your holiday shopping
and outings with your family even more
meaningful this year take a look
hi i'm mark brown ceo of miracle flights
and for 35 years we've been flying sick
children to hospitals all over the
country hi i'm megan i'm the mother to
watson
and he is a miracle flights flyer when
he was still in the womb he was
diagnosed with bilateral clubfoot and
there's really only one specialist
that is trusted in the country to treat
what he has appropriately so every month
we're contacted by hundreds of families
everyone has a unique and compelling
story and in many cases
there may be one doctor one hospital in
the country that a family has to fly to
from las vegas or other cities and they
need to go maybe once a week
once a month or in many cases every week
and that's what we do we'll pay for
those flights for the family and the
sick child so the lights for flights is
amazing i really think that the words
that are scattered around is a true
depiction of exactly what miracle fights
is it's i mean you're soaring it's love
it's all of those beautiful things so
this holiday season we've partnered with
downtown summerlin to bring an amazing
event and we've developed these words
that we hear are so important to our
families and we've had these sign made
and people can come and have a great
instagramable moment in front of the
signs at each sign there's a qr code and
so you simply snap that qr code upload a
picture and you're automatically entered
into a contest to win a 250 dollar gift
card one a week and then at the end
you're also automatically entered to win
a 2500
gift card which will make somebody's
holiday season extra special and so this
little guy has been traveling the world
for 35 years with our kids and now for
the first time thanks to marshall retail
group he's available for sale so every
friday and saturday from four to eight
in front of the dillards plaza for
twenty dollars people can get miles for
their own house and child and all that
money goes directly to help kids fly to
distant medical care
that is so great thank you miracle
flights for sponsoring this segment the
signs are at downtown summerlin
throughout the holiday season so to
learn more just head to
miracleflights.org and remember you can
donate twenty dollars to miracle flights
to receive miles the plush bear he's on
sale every friday and saturday night in
the dillards courtyard